mes chers amis si nous sommes rassemblés
aujourd'hui pour fonder les républicains
c'est d'abord grâce à vous à vous parce
qu'il y a tout juste un
an vous avez voulu sauver notre famille
politique il y a tout juste un an vous
nous avez dit stop aux divisions vous
nous avez demandé de nous
resaisir vous nous avez demandé de nous
rassembler vous avez permis
l'organisation d'une élection
incontestable à la tête de notre famille
politique vous avez choisi Nicolas
Sarkozi comme président et aujourd'hui
vous êtes là pour la Fondation des
républicains alors un seul mot merci à
[Musique]
vous
alors vous avez remarqué les socialistes
le mot républicain ça leura pas
plus il faut dire qu'il y a une grande
différence entre les socialistes et les
républicains les socialistes rêvent tous
les jours de s'appeler républicains mais
personne ne veut aujourd'hui plus
s'appeler
socialiste ces socialistes ils sont
vraiment
imprévisibles est-ce que vous avez
entendu il y a quelques jours cette
phrase prononcée par l'un de leurs
grands responsables je cite le monde il
est pas facile et parfois il est pas
gentil c'est pas une phrase que j'ai
sortie de candis ou d'un extrait des
bisounours non cette phrase elle a été
prononcée par François Hollande le
président de la
République et si je vous en parle c'est
parce que cette phrase elle n'a rien
d'anecdotique elle en dit long sur
l'incapacité des socialistes à
comprendre le monde d'aujourd'hui
empêtré qu'ils sont dans une pensée
d'arrière-garde issue d'un logiciel
périmé cette phrase
elle en dit long sur l'impuissance de la
gauche à armé notre jeunesse face au
défis du monde d'aujourd'hui à lui
permettre de prendre la vague et le vent
de la mondialisation comme toutes les
jeunesses du monde quelle piètre vision
que ce président des bisous s'adressant
à une jeunesse
Calimero François Hollande voulait
réenchanter le rêve français et bien
depuis 3 ans c'est la jeunesse de France
qui
déchante nous les républicains nous ne
pouvons nous résoudre à voir nos enfants
notre jeunesse qui constitue le plus B
actif stratégique de notre pays aussi
malmené laissé au bord du chemin réduit
à choisir entre l'assistana et l'exil
oui notre jeunesse est aujourd'hui
malmenée elle est d'abord malmenée par
le sabotage de l'école je rappelle que
c'était censé être leur priorité mes
chers amis et bien aujourd'hui l'école
elle est anémier elle est appauvrie à
tous les étages appauvrissement des
savoirs et des enseignements avec je
dois dire une espèce de
détermination une persévérance rarement
égalée souvenez-vous ils ont commencé
par vouloir supprimer les notes pour les
remplacer par des smiley vive les
bisounours ils ont ensuite voulu
supprimer les classes préparatoires
c'était l'année dernière mais ils ont
supprimé les internats d'excellence les
bourses au mérite et plus récemment ils
veulent supprimer l'enseignement des
humanités le latin et le grec non
décidément les socialistes n'aiment pas
l'excellence c'est d'ailleurs un peu
paradoxal que François Hollande
pantthéonise d'un côté et que de l'autre
il refuse de se donner les moyens de
faire émerger les grands hommes de
demain
appauvrissement des professeurs avec la
fin des heures supplémentaires je
rappelle que les enseignants étaient les
premiers bénéficiaires des heures
supplémentaires avec la fin des
augmentations que nous avions réussi à
faire plus 18 % pour les enseignants en
début de carrière appauvrissement
managérial avec la fin de l'autonomie
pour les 300 collèges les plus
difficiles de France appauvrissement des
familles décidément mes amis depuis 3
ans les socialistes réussissent cet
exploit prodigieux à l'éducation
nationale détruire ce qui fonctionnait
bien gâcher tout ce qui aurait pu
fonctionner et amplifier ce qui ne
fonctionne
pas ils le font au nom d'un seul
principe
l'égalitarisme
l'égalitarisme socialisme c'est le
poison qu'ils infusent dans la société
française depuis 3 ans
l'égalitarisme c'est le détournement le
dévoiement de la devise républicaine
c'est pour reprendre les propos de Mame
berger ce qui abîme la République
l'égalitarisme c'est le fil conducteur
de la politique socialiste aussi bien
sur l'école sur l'économie sur le
travail sur la fiscalité à l'école au
nom de l'égalitarisme on veut empêcher
les 20 % d'élèves les meilleurs
d'apprendre le latin sous prétexte que
c'est injuste vis-à-vis des 80 % rents
c'est
[Applaudissements]
absurdec au nom de l'égalitarisme on
taxe le travail au niveau du capital au
point que les Américains considèrent que
nous sommes aujourd'hui le seul pays
communiste qui est
réussi dans le droit du travail
aujourd'hui le gouvernement au nom de
l'égalitarisme veut introduire des
représentants syndicaux dans les
entreprises de moins de 11 salariés au
motif que le dialogue social devrait
être le même partout au nom de
l'égalitarisme on supprime
l'apprentissage à 14 ans parce qu'il ne
faut surtout pas qu'un élève puisse
réussir autrement que par la voix du
collège unique la politique des
socialistes en faveur de la jeunesse
c'est la béquille ou le cathéter
l'égalitarisme mes amis conduit au
nivellement par le bas alors nous aurons
à réaffirmer nos valeurs nous aurons à
rappeler qu'il faut d'abord lib les
forces vives du pays qu'il est grand
temps de libérer les forces de progrès
nous sommes le progrès nous sommes le
camp du risque de l'innovation de la
liberté qui fait aujourd'hui la vitalité
de tous les grands pays autour de nous
nous refusons cette vision étriquée
naïve monochrome rose et noir de la
mondialisation nous refusons de teir
notre jeunesse à l'écart de l'économie
de la connaissance nous refusons de
mettre sous cloche la recherche et la
créativité miser sur la recherche miser
sur la jeunesse c'est lui donner un
nouvel horizon c'est prouver que
l'effort le travail l'audace finissent
toujours par payer mes chers amis miser
sur la jeunesse c'est lui montrer que le
talent le mérite sont toujours
récompensés c'est lui redonner le goût
de la Bartier et de l'autonomie c'est le
plus court chemin vers la prospérité
amis républicains c'est notre défi à
nous
merci